LUKMAN RAMSEY:
Welcome, everybody.
Great to see so many people
here late in the day.
I know it's been a long
day for a lot of us.
Hope it's gone
well for you guys.
But a very interesting
talk today,
focused on machine
learning in production
and how to architect for scale.
So I am a member of
the solutions architect
team at Google Cloud.
My role is to basically help
Google Cloud customers use
machine learning
technology, and turn that
into solutions that
ultimately get published
on our cloud.google.com site.
This is a very near
and dear topic to me.
And by the way, I'm going
to be joined later on stage
by a couple of colleagues,
Drew [? Houghton ?] and Kevin
[? Tsai. ?] So I'll be bringing
them up later to talk about
some interesting topics related
to ML and production and how
you scale it.
So let's take a
look at the agenda.
First, we're going
to talk about what
we mean by scale in the
context of machine learning,
because there are some specific
aspects with respect to scaling
that apply to
machine learning that
don't apply to other domains.
We're going to give a
very high-level overview
of architecture for machine
learning on GCP, different ways
that you can do it, some
components and services that we
would typically employ in
a ML production system.
We're going to talk about
Cloud ML Engine, one
of the key services that we
have on Google Cloud for machine
learning in production
and elsewhere.
We're going to talk about
how to use Kubernetes for ML,
and that's where
my colleague Drew
is going to come up and give
you an overview of that.
And then we're going
to focus and drill down
on scaling in the context
of training and prediction.
So there's a lot of content
to get through here.
I'm going to try to move fast so
that we get through all of it.
So let's get started.
So I'd like to start
with this quote
by everybody who has ever
tried, namely, that doing
ML in production is hard.
And if you have tried it, you
probably are aware of this.
So anyway, let's talk about
what do we mean by scale?
When we say ML production
scaling, architecting
for scale, what do we mean?
Well, there's a basic definition
for scale in architecture
in general on
cloud or elsewhere,
that, you know,
as load increases,
we want to maintain
availability and response time.
I mean, that's kind of
a standard definition
for scalability that isn't
really specific to ML.
We want those
characteristics to remain
within acceptable ranges,
right, so as the load increases
on Predict, then we
want to make sure
that the latency associated
with each prediction
stays reasonably
constant or doesn't
fall outside of a range
that would not work for us.
But you know, and again, for
training machine learning,
we care about things like
having the time to convergence,
that it scales kind of in a
reasonable way with the amount
of data that we have, right?
So that's something
that we don't typically
have to concern ourselves
with when we're scaling
in other production contexts.
And then for prediction,
we want to make sure
that as the model
complexity increases,
that the latency associated
with each request also scales
appropriately, that
we don't hit some,
you know, exponential
or some wall
that where suddenly as our
model gets too complex,
our prediction latency
falls off the cliff.
And it's even more
complicated than that
with machine
learning, because you
have to worry about
machine-specific hardware,
machine-learning-specific
hardware, like DPUs and TPUs,
right?
You know, those introduce
different dynamics
into the scaling process.
And furthermore, as you know,
if you're building machine
learning models,
we don't just care
about performance in
training or production,
but also about the process
of building machine learning
models, right?
That has to scale, too.
In other words,
we know that we're
going to have to run hundreds,
maybe thousands of experiments,
and we need a system
that allows us to do that
at scale in an efficient way.
So that's also a
really important thing
to pay attention to, right?
You know, we need to
have a system that
allows us to not just scale
when we're in production,
but scale while we're training
our model in the development
environment.
All right, so let's talk
about the architecture
landscape for ML in
production as it exists today.
This is a rapidly changing
environment, right,
and it's going to be probably a
little bit of a different story
even six months from now.
But as it exists
today, we have a set
of best practices and standard
templates or architectures
that we would use for deploying
ML in production on cloud.
So I just want to start by
making the point that Google
has achieved a scale in the
deployment of production
machine learning that really
probably isn't duplicated
anywhere else, at any other
company in the world, right?
So we have proven that it's
possible to deploy machine
learning models in production at
scale on the order of thousands
of models, right?
In fact, that graph shows--
it doesn't actually
go out to 2018,
but we're now well over
5,000 models in production.
Pipelines that
are in production,
doing machine learning, that are
powering a lot of the services
that you see over
there on the right.
Obviously Search, but Drive,
Translate, Gmail, Maps,
YouTube, and so on.
So machine learning is critical
to all of those services.
And all of those services
are supported by machine
learning pipelines running in
Google's own internal cloud.
So we figured out how to do it.
We had to.
Machine learning is really
core to Google's business.
And this is one of
the keys, the secrets,
that we've developed to solve
that scaling problem internally
at Google.
We published this paper last
year, so it's no secret.
But we have a
common architecture
that we use to build and deploy
our machine learning models
at Google called TFX.
I mean, lesson
number one from that
is that having a common
architecture that you use
to build and deploy
and serve your models
is critical, right, if you're
going to do it at scale.
And so we realized
that for a long time.
We built this TFX
common architecture
based on the learnings
of many, many years
of doing this in production.
And the other point
that I want to make
about scaling in general--
this applies particularly
to Google Cloud,
and we're going to
assume that in this talk,
that we're really talking about
serverless architecture, right?
So it's going to be
a lot harder for you
to scale if you're worried
about individual servers
for your training
cluster or even your data
pre-processing pipeline.
And GCP is explicitly designed
to leverage serverless
architecture for all
parts of this pipeline.
So we're going to assume that
we're talking about serverless.
That kind of takes a lot
of the stuff off the table
with respect to scaling.
But serverless architecture is
going to be key for scaling.
So this is a high-level
architecture diagram of TFX.
It was present in the paper.
There's actually a talk in
the TensorFlow Dev Summit
that you can go out and
find on YouTube that
talks about this architecture.
Not all of this has
been open sourced.
There are a few
components of TFX
that have been open
sourced, and we do plan,
and we have explicitly
announced as such,
on open sourcing
the entire stack,
but it's not all done yet.
In particular, we have model
evaluation and validation,
TF model analysis, it
was just open sourced.
On the data transformation
side, there is TF Transform.
We've open sourced a serving
component as well, TF Serving.
We actually did that last year.
So by the way, those components
are the same components
that Google uses in production
for our own internal workloads.
So if you use these
components, you're
basically running on
the same code as Google.
But for each of these
architectural components
that you would use in a common
architecture for machine
learning in production,
there are GCP services
that correspond to those.
I'm not going to go
through all of them
just in the interest of time.
I do want to point out that--
yeah, so those are all the
services, the hexagons for GCP
that correspond to each
of those components.
Like I said, I'm not going
to go through the whole thing
in detail.
I do want to point out, again,
some of the key components
that you would use--
not TFX-based, right
but services on GCP
that you would use to
solve these problems.
So for training, ML Engine
and GKE are basically
Kubernetes with Kubeflow
sitting on top of it,
are two of the best
answers we have for that.
We're going to talk in more
detail about each of those
later.
For tuning, ML Engine offers a
hyperparameter tuning service,
and if you haven't
taken advantage of it,
you really should.
It's one of the
key differentiators
for Google and for Google
Cloud in the realm of machine
learning.
In fact, I'm not aware
of another cloud service
that offers a tuning
service like this.
You know, this
means adjusting all
of the knobs on your ML models
to optimize their performance.
Model evaluation and validation,
I mentioned TFX model analysis.
It's very critical,
actually, so that you
can understand how your model
is performing across all
of your data sets, and if
there's a slice of the data,
for example, that it's
not performing well on.
It's also critical for things
like explainability in ML,
which I would love to talk
about more, but we won't.
But you have to be
able to break down
different slices
of your input data
in order to understand how
your model's really performing
in production.
And then finally, as I
mentioned, for serving
we have TF Serving, which
again would typically
be deployed on Kubernetes
on GKE and ML Engine,
as answers to that.
So let's talk a little bit
more about Cloud ML Engine.
Cloud ML Engine has
been out for a while.
It's quite robust now.
We have a lot of
customers using it
for all kinds of
different workloads.
It's a platform as as a
service for TensorFlow,
but as you know, not
just TensorFlow anymore.
So you can run xgboost
or scikit-learn
on Cloud ML Engine.
And again, it basically serves
as on-demand infrastructure
for machine learning.
So you can set up clusters
to do your training jobs.
Once you've trained
your model, then you
can take that same model and
deploy it as a cloud end point,
as a rest end point.
So you can seamlessly transition
from training to prediction.
It offers some built-in
model version management.
And then basically, you're
still just using TensorFlow,
so you could take that model.
There's nothing locking you in.
You can take that model
and download it and run it
elsewhere on premise, you
know, even on another cloud.
So for our purposes
here, for scalability,
the pros of ML Engine
are that it's very easy
to scale up in terms of asking
for more capacity for more
workers.
You just basically specify
that in your training job.
And it's also nice that
the serving capability
is automatic.
There's been some
recent improvements
in things like startup latency
and other aspects of serving.
We're just about to announce
increased capability
to use GPUs for Cloud ML Engine.
So it's got a number
of advantages.
The cons, I would say,
are associated with,
you know, using distributed
TensorFlow, which is just not
easy, no matter
how you slice it.
Again, we're working
on the TensorFlow team
to make that easier,
but it's still
got some gotchas
associated with it.
We're going to talk a bit
more about that later,
and how you can navigate that.
There are some
limited limitations,
you know, like limited
machine types, which again,
we're working on resolving.
So again, there's
some limitations
in the service that make it
not ideal for some cases.
But it's still quite a
very powerful service.
You know, with serving
for example, again,
ML Engine, in terms
of scalability,
you're not in charge
of provisioning
the number of machines.
There are some knobs and
parameters that you can tweak,
but essentially it
scales according
to your load, which is great.
All right, for the
section on Kubernetes
for machine learning,
I'm going to bring up
my colleague Drew [? Houghton ?]
on the CEML specialist team,
and have him tell
you a bit about that.
[? DREW HOUGHTON: ?] Awesome.
Thank you, Lukman.
So for this section,
we're going to talk
about the best of two
worlds that I work
with customers quite a lot on.
One is Kubernetes, and
one is machine learning.
And let's take a look
at how Kubernetes
can help solve some
of the problems,
totally in open source and
across multiple clouds.
So ML in production,
for those of us
that have tried or have
done ML in production,
we know that we care about these
three things-- composability,
portability, and scalability.
And let's talk
about each of those.
First is composability.
When you solve an ML
problem on your laptop,
it's easy to solve
some problems maybe
on Kaggle on your laptop, small
to medium dataset, with what I
call, it's kind of what I
call toy machine learning.
You solve the problem, maybe
you won the competition,
but that's not the same
as taking your solution,
scaling it, and
making it worthwhile,
and frankly, you know, worth
the money and the effort
for the enterprise.
There's a lot of things that
come after that, not just
the tuning and
building the model,
but deploying it at scale,
refreshing your model
every week, day, 15 minutes, if
you have cold start problems.
AB testing and model evaluation,
and serving at scale, right?
The reality is that to do each
of these different portions
of the pipeline, there's
different systems.
We have data ingestion.
So you know, where's
the data coming from?
Is it real time?
Is it streaming?
Is it from a variety
of different systems?
Who's putting it all
together in a data lake?
We have our data
analysis and validation.
So this is exploring
the data, understanding
what we can actually model
or glean from the data.
Then we actually have the
model building itself,
the training, the
hyperparameter tuning,
and lastly the serving,
serving at scale,
keeping the model fresh.
Now in practice, these are
often different people, if not
different entire teams, doing
this at scale in production,
right?
So there's different very
different skill sets,
very different systems.
And it makes sense, right?
These are very
different problems.
One of the promises of ML
is that we sort of unify
a lot of our data.
We apply an algorithm
to a business problem.
We do it in real time.
Now, this is great.
But when you have lots
of teams involved,
lots of systems involved, it can
become more difficult to scale.
Every time you deploy
a model, do you
have to get every team involved?
So we care about composability.
Essentially, reusing
different pieces
from each stage with sort of
limited engagement or friction
each time I want
to build a model.
For example,
building a model that
can be used by a
software engineer
in the future on similar data
without having to go back
to that ML researcher.
Now, some of us also care
a lot about portability.
So just show of hands
in the room, who's using
Kubernetes or has
explored Kubernetes?
A lot of hands, right.
That's awesome to see.
And these days,
definitely the best
place to run
containers at scale.
One of the great
things about Kubernetes
is the way we've
abstracted the compute,
you can take your
application and move it
very easily from your laptop
to the on-premise cluster
to one of various
cloud providers.
And this is something very
important to lots and lots
of organizations.
We hear this again and again.
Also, we have great
primitives in Kubernetes
with dealing with
things like this.
So Joe Beata, one of the
co-founders of Kubernetes,
says, the way I think about it,
every difference between dev
stage and production will
eventually result in an outage.
And it's very easy in
Kubernetes, at least
easier than in a lot
of other systems,
of treating things like
dev staging and prod
as sort of first-class citizens
that the app understands,
and helps to limit the
problems you're going to face.
So let's talk about portability
with machine learning.
Now, because machine
learning is such a compute-
and performance-intensive
application,
we actually care a lot about
all the different pieces
of our system, all the
way down to the hardware.
But it's not just the hardware,
it's up to the drivers.
Anyone had problems
installing drivers,
and takes a long time
before you can actually
start working on your problem?
Can be quite a nightmare.
The frameworks, they
change very quickly.
You know, this is a very
rapidly moving space.
There's a lot of
effort that goes
into building the stack on a
laptop, getting data training,
getting the model working.
You're super lucky if
it converges right away.
But again, this is great for
solving a toy ML problem.
What happens if I want
a skill, or I want
to deploy this in production?
Now, I'm dealing with
different environments, right?
Maybe I have a training
rig in the back,
you know, cooling the office.
Maybe I'm using an
on prem cluster.
We have existing significant
GPU or CPU investments.
Maybe this isn't
a cloud provider.
We're multiplying the complexity
of keeping these environments
in sync.
It was already hard enough
to get the laptop up
and running that
environment perfect for what
we wanted to do.
It gets even more complex.
So pop quiz.
What's really good at
composability, portability,
and scalability?
Kubernetes, you got it.
Containers in Kubernetes.
And guess what?
Google runs all of our machine
learning on containers,
and essentially, you know,
Borg, but the influence
behind Kubernetes.
So this can be done.
And we have some great news.
Kubernetes today has a
lot of great primitives
and support for machine
learning workloads.
We support accelerators
in a very easy to use,
extensible manner.
So GPUs are in beta,
TPUs are in alpha.
With just one line in
your communities manifest,
you can request
GPUs for your pods.
It's really easy to
schedule lots of GPUs
and bring lots of horsepower
to your workloads.
The existing controllers
in Kubernetes
also simplify a lot of the
DevOps challenges we face.
Let's remember,
the reason we want
to use Kubernetes here
is we get lots of wins
from the infrastructure
standpoint,
from the repeatability
and from the DevOps standpoint.
We want to apply those wins to
our machine learning workloads.
Some of the ways it does
this is Kubernetes Jobs.
So when I create
a Kubernetes Job,
maybe this is a training
job, Kubernetes will then
go create a pod or multiple pods
to try and complete that job.
If a node fails, let's say
I'm using preemptable nodes
or preemptable GPUs,
it will take that job,
it'll schedule it
somewhere else for me.
If I'm using, say, the
TensorFlow Estimator
API, I'm checkpointing
regularly,
my job is all of a sudden
stateless, in a way.
You know, Kubernetes
will recreate the pod,
it'll keep training somewhere
else in the data center.
We also have
Kubernetes deployments,
which are great for serving.
So you tell Kubernetes what
your deployment looks like,
where the container is
or where the model is,
how fast you want
to scale it, and it
does all the rest for you.
As your load
increases, Kubernetes
will create more
pods on your behalf.
It also scales.
At this point, I
think Kubernetes
will scale up to 5,000
nodes, and that's
increasing quite rapidly.
And we also have container-based
images for ML workloads.
So in some cases,
you don't actually
have to build your
own containers.
You can use an off-the-shelf
TensorFlow CPU container,
and then there's
a GPU container.
And if you're comfortable
with code control,
you can actually just load
your code up at runtime.
There's benefits to building
your own containers,
but you don't even
need to to get started
using Kubernetes for ML.
So this is great.
We have the right primitives.
We have the right tools
that Kubernetes supports.
But a lot of things
I just talked about,
if you're a data scientist or
machine learning researcher,
might not be as
familiar to you, right?
Maybe you feel like I need
to learn about containers,
container building,
end points for serving,
persistent volumes, scaling,
all these things, before I
can be really effective with
machine learning on Kubernetes.
You know, we see
the promise here.
We like that we can get
a consistent environment
or we can get a similar
environment on prem
to the cloud, but there's
a lot of other things
we still have to build.
So the good news is,
we have an answer.
And that is Kubeflow.
So Kubeflow is an
open source project
whose goal is to make
it easy for everyone
to learn, deploy, and manage
portable, distributed machine
learning on Kubernetes.
So basically, to get all those
infrastructure Kubernetes
wins, but make it
really easy for those
that aren't Kubernetes experts.
And this is a trend we're seeing
more and more in the Kubernetes
world, higher-level
frameworks that
make it really easy to
solve a particular problem.
So what does Kubeflow get us?
It gets us composability.
We have a variety of existing
popular open source tools.
I'll dive into those
in a little bit.
We use ksonnet for packaging
and easily setting up
your environment.
So all of a sudden, des,
staging, production, laptop,
are all first-class citizens.
And with just a
couple of commands,
you can deploy to each of
them the same exact code.
It's very portable.
Kubeflow is totally open source,
using totally open source
components.
And a lot of those
components are
cloud native, Kubernetes
native components.
I'll talk about those
in just a second.
What's great is that the
huge community that's
built up around Kubernetes
is solving your deployment
problems so you can focus on
the actual machine learning
problem.
And lastly, it's
scalable, right?
TensorFlow already supports
CPU, GPU, TPU, distributed.
Kubernetes scales like crazy.
We can use that power to
handle our serving workloads
and our training workloads.
So what does this look
like, and how does
this solve this whole mess?
Well, for those
of you that know,
Kubernetes will actually
solve a lot of it for you.
That's why we were looking
at Kubernetes as a solution,
right?
So I'll kind of
go back and forth.
Kubernetes will give you
a pretty consistent API
up to the runtime.
So I don't have to worry
about this anymore.
I have abstracted my compute
to a really nice level,
and I don't have to worry
about keeping it in sync.
Now, that said, you're still
having to worry traditionally
about the framework, what my
storage is, maybe drivers.
Kubeflow, with just
a couple of commands,
can be installed on
Minikube on your laptop.
Minikube is a local mini
Kubernetes cluster running
in a VM, but you get the
same API on your laptop
as if you were in a 5,000 node
cluster with thousands of GPUs.
A couple commands,
you can install
Kubeflow on your laptop, on your
on-premise existing cluster,
on various cloud clusters.
And now you have a consistent
ML-ready environment
across wherever you do compute.
So what's included in Kubeflow?
So we actually just
released version 0.2.
So we are earlier in
the days of Kubeflow,
but this is developing
very rapidly,
because customers do want a
solution that spans across
clouds.
For some customers,
being totally open source
is very important.
Running in multiple clouds
and on prem is very important.
Same reasons we've seen the
popularity with Kubernetes
in general.
What's included
today is JupyterHub
for collaborative,
interactive training.
A TensorFlow training
controller, so now
you don't have to
tell Kubernetes
what a TensorFlow
training job looks like
or how to do
distributed TensorFlow.
You just tell it, hey, here's
my code, run it distributed.
Very similar to how you would
do with Cloud ML Engine.
Same thing with serving.
You don't have to
tell Kubernetes
what TensorFlow serving is.
You just say, here's my model,
go serve it and auto-scale it.
We have Argo for workflows.
So creating a
consistent pipeline
from pre-processing to
training, hyperparameter
tuning and validation.
SeldonCore for complex
inference and non TF-models.
I want to stress that this
is not just for TensorFlow.
We have PyTorch in alpha.
We definitely have people
running scikit, xgboost,
and SeldonCore.
You can run whatever
frameworks you want.
Also in 0.2, we released
hyperparamter tuning
and Ambassador for
reverse proxies.
So this is a very
rapidly moving project.
All right, and then
for our next section,
I'm going to invite Kevin
up for scaling training.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: So I'm going to
have Kevin come up now and talk
about scaling
training, in particular
about the challenges of doing
distributed training on GPUs.
Thanks, Kevin.
[? KEVIN TSAI: ?]
Thanks, Lukman.
OK.
One of the very common questions
that we get from the community
is I had GPU, and I just
upgraded my VM24 GPUs,
but training is just as slow.
What's going on, right?
If you take a step
back and try to think
about what you're
doing with TensorFlow,
you're creating a graph and
then you're executing the graph,
right?
And by default if
you don't specify
where your graph
goes and TensorFlow
sees one or more GPUs, it will
throw the operations in GPU 0,
right?
So there's a really nice tool
from NVIDIA called NVIDIA SMI.
If you run that during
training, you'll
be able to see how
busy your GPUs are.
If you run it on
multiple GPUs and you
see something like this,
right, that probably
means that you created a graph
that only had busyness in GPU 0
right?
So that's actually
the expected behavior
if you don't specify
parallelization
over multiple GPUs.
So let's take a look at a
very simple model, right?
And we use this to
describe what we're trying
to do in parallelization.
One of the ways to parallelize
across multiple GPS
is called data parallelism.
And basically what
you're doing is
you are replicating your entire
model across two or more GPUs,
and then you go ahead and
divide up the data coming in
into smaller batches.
So let's say, for example,
if your batch size is 256,
and you split it over GPUs,
you have 128 go to the GPU 0,
128 go to GPU 1, right?
So that's pretty
straightforward.
The other way of parallelizing
is called model parallelism,
and typically, you wouldn't use
this unless you get to a point
where your model is
really big, or you're
running out of memory and
GPUs and so forth, right?
And it's actually also possible
to put model parallelism
and data parallelism together.
Now, one of the challenges
when where we're splitting data
into two or more GPUs,
right, is at the end,
you're going to end up
with multiple result sets.
So if you think about
the predictions,
you started with 256,
128 goes to one side
and 128 goes to the other side.
The prediction's actually
pretty straightforward.
You just concatenate
that, right?
But gradient's a little
bit more complex.
So what we normally
do with gradients
coming from the two GPUs, we'll
go ahead and average that,
right?
And one of the things that
we also found at Google
is, to have the best
chance of convergence,
what we want to do is we want
to do synchronous replication,
meaning that after each
batch, you want to calculate
the gradient,
apply the gradient,
update the parameters, and then
go to the next batch, right?
That's the best performance.
But that also means that
the gradient averaging
becomes a blocking process.
So it's very important that
we have a very fast method
of applying the gradients.
So one of the ways that
we could do that is just
go ahead and use a CPU as
the consolidation mechanism.
So after each batch, the GPUs
would each copy the gradients
to the CPU, and the CPU would
go ahead and average it out,
make the update stop, and
redistribute the parameters
back across all the GPUs.
And that's one way to do it.
But as you already
kind of see over here,
if we increase the
number of GPUs,
you're going to increase
the number of copies
you have to average out,
and then that becomes
a bottleneck, right?
So a more performant
way of doing it
is to use an all reduce type
of mechanism to go ahead
and do the distribution, right?
The other advantage of doing
an all reduce type mechanism
is that you could take advantage
of the very fast NV link,
right, whereas like
if you're going
to let the CPU do
the consolidation,
you have to go through PCIE.
So when it comes to machine
learning, PCIE is slow, right?
Just remember that.
PCIE is actually really slow.
OK.
So if you take a step back, here
are the kind of the options.
If you were to go ahead and
choose a distribution strategy
or distribution
method today, here
are kind of like, at the
high level, what would
you could choose from.
So if you have a single
server, it's not too hard,
a lot of built-in capabilities
within TensorFlow and Keras
that's available.
So ever since 1.5, we
have replicate_model_fn.
And within Keras, Keras actually
had their multi-GPU model
strategy even before
TensorFlow did.
But in both cases,
you have to remember
that these are
CPU-bound, right, meaning
they use a CPU as a
consolidation strategy,
whereas in TensorFlow 1.8, we
introduced mirrored strategy,
which is part of a larger family
called distribution strategy.
And mirrored strategy
currently is single server,
but multiple GPUs, and it
uses the all reduced type
of mechanism as well.
Now, if one server
is not good enough,
there are also options for
multiple servers, right?
And so you might have heard
[INAUDIBLE] talk about TPUs.
So TPU is one of the options to
go ahead and go very parallel.
The other option, there's
an open source project
called Horovod put together
by a couple of really
smart engineers at Uber.
So that gives you the ability
to scale over multiple servers
with multiple GPUs as well.
And distribution
[INAUDIBLE],, again,
is going to be offered as a
multi-server option as well.
Now, one mention is, if you
look at the older TensorFlow
documentation, there's
mention of parameter server
and workers.
Because this method is
not as effective in coming
to convergence compared
to the other methods, what
we recommend is, that's
probably not the first solution
that you should look at.
OK, so just want to
spend a little time
on distribution strategy.
So what we realized
is a lot of users
already have a lot of
code that's written,
and we want to be
able to make it
so that you can kind of shoehorn
this capability into your code
without a lot of changes.
So what we've done is, we
have put this capability
into run_config.
So you specify a distribution
strategy-- in this case,
mirrored strategy--
and you would go ahead and put
that as one of the parameters
within run_config, and you
create the estimator that way,
right?
And if you're using
Keras, we also
support the model to
estimator conversion,
and within there,
you'll go ahead
and specify run_config as well.
Thanks.
LUKMAN RAMSEY: Thank you, Kevin.
Thank you.
So we heard a lot of really
interesting information
about how to scale
using Kubernetes
as a common architecture
and Kubeflow.
And we also heard some really
interesting information
about distributing
over multiple GPUs.
And again, we
will, as a company,
always continue to
support and encourage
people to leverage GPUs on
our Google Cloud environment.
We also, as you know, provide
our own hardware acceleration
option TPUs, and so I'm
going talk just a little
bit about that as well.
So TPUs are now at
version 1 and 2.
Both of those have been
deployed in Google Cloud.
Well, TPU version 1 was
actually deployed internally
in Google's
infrastructure onboard.
TPU version 2 has been made
available to our customers
at Google Cloud, and today,
we announced TPU version 3.
Actually, I think we
announced that at I/O.
But anyway, we're continuing
on developing and improving
that architecture,
and you should
expect TPU 3.0 to
be launched sometime
later this year, in cloud.
And the way we make this
available to our customers
on cloud is something called
Cloud TPU, which is essentially
a service that wraps around TPU
resources that live in a pod
and make it easy for you to do
your training jobs using TPUs.
This is a quick
example of sort of what
that looks like in code.
Essentially, as Kevin
mentioned, you know,
it's just simple as basically
using a TPU estimator instead
of a regular estimator.
And then there are
some other things
you have to do to
connect to a cloud TPU,
but it's designed to be
relatively simple to do.
And we do have a lot
of customers now taking
advantage of TPUs.
So for certain
kinds of workloads,
It can be quite effective.
Again, this is an example
of another code change
that one could use in order
to take advantage of TPUs.
So just using a TPU
version of the optimizer.
Again, it's not for
every problem, right?
You need to have enough data
and enough need for scale
in order to justify the
work that you do in order
to customize for TPU.
So again, situations where
you've got very large models
with very large batch
sizes, the models
need to be able to run on TPUs,
so not all models currently do.
Just worth pointing out.
We will get there eventually,
but even as of today,
there are certain operations
that would not be supported.
So you may have a model
that just won't run on TPU.
And you don't want to use Cloud
TPU for very small models,
or models with lots of branches,
or again, that use operations
that aren't supported.
All right.
We can talk a little bit about
input pipeline performance.
That's another key
aspect of scaling
with respect to training.
So the first point
I want to make
is that if you're not using
the TF data API, you should be,
all right?
This is, as of about a
year ago or so, basically
our recommended architecture
for building data pipelines
in TensorFlow.
Again, there are older
methods out there
using input cues and so on.
But we really strongly
recommend that you use this API
to specify your data pipelines.
But just using
this API by itself
doesn't necessarily
get you there, right?
So this is an example of a
ResNet 50 data set API, coded,
you know, simply.
I mean, there's nothing wrong
with the way this is coded,
but you get through this
about 150 images per second.
And really, you should be able
to expect for this image net
problem, you know, something
over 1,000 images per second.
So what is the issue
with this code,
and what can we
do to optimize it?
Well, again, the
way, when you're
approaching the optimization
of input pipelines,
we suggest that you
think is like ETL.
Basically, separate the
process of extracting the data
from the storage, transforming
that data to prepare it
for training, which
typically has to happen,
and then loading that
data into the accelerator.
Think of those in
distinct phases,
because different parts
of the infrastructure
are going to be
dedicated to that.
And so if you can segment
those processes such
that those different
pieces of infrastructure
are allowed to
operate in parallel,
then you're going to get
much better throughput.
So here's an example where
the operations are serialized
at a very high level, you know,
with the time going forward.
And the extract transform and
load, and then train steps,
are all synchronous
with each other.
Here-- and of
course, you would see
that the various
components of the system
are going to be idle at any
given point in that cycle,
right?
Your CPU is idle.
If your CPU is doing
the data transformation,
it's idle while it's waiting
for the next data set
to come through.
And similarly, if you're
using hardware acceleration
in this kind of
scheme, you're going
to see low GPU
utilization, right?
That's when you run
that NVIDIA SMI tool,
and you see something like
25% or 40% utilization.
It's often because of
input pipelining issues.
So this is what you want
to see instead, where
the processes of extraction,
transformation, and loading
are all parallelized
sufficiently such
that your training
infrastructure, your GPUs,
or your custom hardware, the
utilization is maximized.
So again, we don't
have time here
to talk about all of
the tricks of the trade
that you use to do this,
but just let's note here
that the dataset API
is really designed
to parallelize in the same
way that we just discussed.
So again, if you parallelize
that mapping operation that's
expressed here across
multiple cores,
just by adding a parameter
to the function call,
that's enough to achieve
parallelization there,
similarly.
And that by itself gets you from
150 images per second to 600,
right.
But there's more you can do.
So you can also parallelize
the reading, essentially
the extract step.
And you can parallelize the
prefetch step that basically
allows the data set to be queued
up so you can feed it faster
into the GPU.
And with those two changes,
just with the same code,
again, it's basically
the same pipeline,
just with some extra
parallelization primitives
or parameters added to it.
We get to over 1,750
images per second.
So just the point
to make here is
that it's very critical to
tune your input pipelines,
and that can make a huge,
huge difference in the way
that your training
process scales.
So we're not going to talk
about scaling prediction.
And this is a number of
interesting topics here.
We're going to talk about
how you optimize your model.
There's a tool within
TensorFlow that's
been around for a while that's
not probably widely appreciated
called Graph Transform Tool
that we would encourage
you to make use of to optimize
your models for prediction.
We cold talk a little
bit about quantization
and what that is, why
you care about that,
what you'd use that for.
TensorFlow Lite, which is a new
framework that's specifically
targeted to make models
run fast on mobile.
Actually, it's a
framework for quantization
on mobile specifically.
We're going to talk
about TensorRT,
which is a great framework
from our partners at NVIDIA
that makes it really fast to
serve models that leverage some
of the capabilities of
the NVIDIA hardware.
And then finally,
we're going to touch
on some serving
optimizations that you
can make the TF Serving to
make serving process go faster.
So what is Graph Transform Tool?
Well, it's actually present
in the TensorFlow code base.
It has been since
I think pre-1.0.
And it has a number
of operations
that are very useful
when you're optimizing
your graph for serving.
So one of the
things that you want
to do, typically
the serving graph,
there's some components
in the training graph
that aren't necessary
for the serving graph.
And GTT tool allows you
to strip those unneeded
nodes out of your graph, just
to make it more efficient,
make it a lighter footprint
and faster for serving.
Again, it will do
graph optimization,
so it will remove nodes
that aren't doing anything,
the identity nodes.
There's various other
nodes that are typically
included in the graph that are
needed for training that aren't
needed for predict if you use
batch normalization, which
is another topic that I'd love
to have spent some time on.
If you're not using
batch normalization
and you're training a
deep neural network,
you're not doing it right.
You're not following
the best practice.
You need to use
batch normalization.
Let's just leave it at that.
There is some
information out there
that you can go find
to incorporate that.
It's pretty easy to
do in TensorFlow.
You will find anywhere from
20% to sometimes more percent
uplift in both training accuracy
and speed to convergence, just
by using batch normalization.
It's a best practice.
There's no researcher in deep
learning that's not using it.
So it does some
calculation that makes
batch normalization go faster.
So that's another capability
of the Graph Transform Tool,
and several other
useful transforms,
including the ability
to quantize your graph.
So what is quantization?
Well, it turns out that
weights, 32-bit weights,
are quite useful for
training, but for serving,
we can often get away
with much lower precision,
like even down to 8-bit weights.
Actually, there are folks out
there doing 1-bit weights,
believe it or not.
But certainly without
losing a lot of accuracy,
but achieving a huge speed
up in serving performance,
you can go from 32-bit
weights to 8-bit weights.
This is a very common practice,
particularly again when
you're deploying on smaller
devices like mobile devices
or devices on the edge,
it's even more important,
because model size
really matters.
But so you get a big uplift
in both speed and [? not, ?]
sometimes, a little bit
of trade off in accuracy,
but typically not that much
if you do this correctly.
TensorFlow has built-in
support for quantization.
So how does this work?
Well, essentially, during
your training process,
you're computing basically
the minimum and maximum value
of these parameters,
say weights.
You're storing that as
metadata along with the weight,
and that allows you
basically to scale the weight
from wherever it occupies in its
range down to this 8-bit range.
So you don't just
store the weight,
you store a minimum
and maximum value.
So it makes the graph a
little bit more complicated.
But you know, it's much, much
faster to do these things with
8-bit values than it is with--
There's no loss in performance.
You get a little bit
extra of model complexity,
but you get a big
increase in performance.
So it's relatively
straightforward to do this,
again using the
Graph Transform Tool.
There's actually other another
tool in the TensorFlow code
base that can be used for
quantization, called Quantized
Graph, I believe.
We'd recommend that you
use this tool, frankly.
I mean, they're both
roughly comparable,
but Graph Transform Tool allows
you to incorporate several
of the other transforms
that are going
to be useful when you're
doing this to a model
prior to serving.
TensorFlow Lite is
worth mentioning here.
This was announced at the
recent TensorFlow Dev Summit,
and it's a framework
built into TensorFlow
that basically does this
quantization process specified
for mobile devices or
customized for mobile devices.
So this just shows you a
graph of the relative gain
in performance between
the TensorFlow model
and a TensorFlow Lite
quantized model running
on a mobile device.
And I would encourage
you, if you're
interested in running ML
on mobile, to check out
this talk on the
TensorFlow Dev Summit.
It's available on YouTube and
goes into much more detail
about TensorFlow Lite.
Finally, I'd to
talk about TensorRT.
So our great partners
at NVIDIA have basically
been working on this
problem themselves--
how do we optimize
inference given a model?
And they've also built some
quantization capabilities
into the hardware.
So the V100 chip,
for example, includes
what are called tensor
cores, which are essentially
custom hardware components
or chip components that
are optimized to
execute inference
on these quantized values.
And TensorRT is a
library that they
provide that they've worked
with the TensorFlow team
to integrate directly
into TensorFlow.
And so it's relatively
straightforward,
and you can get really,
really good performance
boosts, particularly
on the chips
like the V100 that have
specialized hardware
to support this.
So again, if you're
deploying inference on V100s,
you've got to use
TensorRT, or else you're
giving up something that could
be on the order of 10x, maybe
20x factors for performance.
Finally, I just want
to talk a little bit
about some
optimizations that you
can do to TensorFlow Serving.
And then I think we'll have
maybe two minutes or so left
for questions.
I'm amazed that we got
through all of this.
If we don't have time, if there
are more questions than we have
time for here, then
myself and Drew and Kevin
are going to be out in
the hallway afterwards.
So we're fine with you
guys approaching us,
and we'll answer as many
questions as we can out there.
All right, so let's talk
about optimizing TF Serving.
Well, there's
really one thing you
have to care about
when you're optimizing
TF Serving for scale,
and it's really important
if you're going to do
TF Serving on GPUs.
You won't actually get the
benefit of the GPU acceleration
unless you do this, which
is to optimize the batching.
So basically, this
means instead of feeding
a single predict example through
your TF Serving pipeline,
you batch them
together in bunches,
and you execute those all in
parallel through the pipeline.
And there is some
tuning of this process.
There is a batching
guide, TensorFlow Serving
batching guide, that's in
the source for TF Serving.
And I would encourage you, if
you're using TF Serving at all,
that you read this and
pay attention to it,
because it can make a
big difference in the way
that your TF Serving
pipeline performs.
Well, that is it.
Thank you very much.